and to make small bets five percent of
your net worth or less is what i always
tell people when they're doing
experimental stuff
how much of your net worth is in crypto
okay
so this this question again is it's a
disclaimer right because i said yeah i
have no
uh fiat so like i am 99 percent invested
in crypto
okay do you own your own home no
no i have no house i have no car i have
no physical property so if the crypto
bubble were to pop like the dot-com one
did and lose 90
of its value you would literally lose 90
of your net worth
but like yeah but that's okay because my
burn rate is like
three thousand dollars a month got it
okay
um are you open to unsolicited feedback
ah please please please i i i think
you've done okay
and if you could spend 70 million on an
nft i think it's okay for you to buy a
really nice house
and then buy a second really nice house
like
this is my best advice to you literally
20
20 of your net worth put because trust
me it's not going to make a difference
in the end
and it's a great downside protection for
you to have the best penthouse in
singapore
and the best island beach retreat you'll
get use out of them
yeah promise me promise me you'll
diversify just 10 percent
okay will you diversify 10 so so here's
my answer right like
i'm i'm planning to do that and i'm i've
already you know started working on it
but the thing is i didn't get here
because of of a choice of just keeping
everything in crypto
it was not a choice i don't come from
the us you should understand that i come
from a country
where if i had physical property and i
was who i am
i was i might not have that physical
property today
because oh explain which country is this
i'm from india
right and so what you're saying is you
can't
the system there is not trustworthy yeah
like
you you think like physical prop like
property rights is not the same
across the world and that's the that's
the motivation for me to be in crypto
right
now i can say okay in singapore maybe
it's it's safer
but like five years ago three years ago
right like when i when i wanted to buy a
property in india
it was always in my head where i was
thinking because
you can be targeted right like every
individual is a minority
ah see this is a fascinating discussion
i'm coming to it from the american
perspective
where i've never seen anybody have their
home taken from them in fact if you want
to build a highway here
or when they were building the net
stadium in brooklyn
there were people who held out and were
like i'm not giving you my house and the
government's like imminent domain and
they were like
fu i'm going to fight it forever and we
literally have instances where people
in fact do you ever see the movie the
pixar movie up
yeah yeah yeah with the balloons like
literally the premise of that is there's
an old man in a house
where he grew up with his sweetheart or
his wife and she passed away and he just
doesn't want to give up the home
yeah and no matter how much money they
give him so we have in our
hearts and souls this idea that it's
your property
you have it forever but you come from a
world where that's actually not how
the world works and it's one of the
beautiful things about crypto in this
moment in time
is that we all get to see uh a different
perspective when coming to the table to
you cryptos less risk to me it's more
risk
it's a really fascinating moment that's
truly america right like i'm having
goosebumps right now
but i'm telling this to people crypto
isn't like if america is an idea crypto
is just
the new america right and crypto
is the new america because it's freedom
it's freedom and open borders and like i
i came from india i didn't i didn't grow
up in the us
i didn't and i didn't grow up in the in
in the west
uh until my uh until i was 16 i grew up
in a small town in india
and i got the same opportunity to invest
in ethereum as a guy from san francisco
and i'm like wow this is amazing
right yeah and so that's how i made my
money so whatever you see today and the
people story
this whole 669 million story also is
very powerful
because it's the story of crypto more
than it being a story of just me
right the credits to the same industry
and credits for the generous people
who decided to share the piece of the
pie listen you're a fascinating guy
any closing comments you want to make
sure sure so um
like a bit about nfts right like um a
lot of people look at
nfts as you know a like interesting new
investment asset definitely is and
and you know there's there's a lot of
risk involved in it but
i feel like there's there's more angles
to it no more angles to look at at nft
so
uh you could you could be a collector
for a narrative for a cause uh you could
also be an artist for a cause
not just you know like take taking your
digital art and putting it online but
you can really support a cause with it
right and it's a visual medium so
nfts are are are a great way
to support a specific cause you you you
are
um you are really fond of and it's going
to
it's going to hold its its value over
time
based on the community that's around it
right so again this is a huge risk it's
not like
nfts will make you money but it's a nice
way
to even think about it as um as a
philanthropic thing
right like it's there are angles to it
there are angles to it so
so i i would urge people especially the
people who made a lot of
money uh in crypto i urge them to buy
art
right like i i urge them to say like
take a little bit of your money
and maybe buy a little bit of digital
art and and and make a gallery in the
virtual world
and hang them and i'll come and i'll
come and visit it love it
i love it um and i just i think we'll
end with if america was an idea
crypto is the new america it means
freedom it means open borders and global
accessibility
it means ownership of property uh what a
great great uh discussion this has been
and uh really appreciate you taking the
time i know you've got
a zillion other things to do but i can't
wait to meet you in person but here we
go
lightning round as quick as you can if
you do not own bitcoin what
cryptocurrencies are in your portfolio
paul could not okay
uh anon asks how would you recommend a
young content creator start utilizing or
investing in nfts i think you answered
that like
do things you enjoy with art anything
else and and probably
uh be at the meet-ups so there are
virtual meetups uh
one called whip w vip work in progress
yeah so if you
search for it yeah it's it's the best
place to get started and be part of the
community
love it veronica asks what are uh
medikovan's thoughts on the upcoming
pack action pak auction rather
what is the pack auction do you know um
yeah like yeah like auction right like
pack is doing a saw the
drop uh i think it's interesting i i
want to observe it
i don't have a like particular opinion
about it and
okay uh yeah i i don't know if i'm
participating so so i don't want to
comment on it cody asks where can we
see experience medicovin's collection
um the best way right now is just going
on openc uh we are
building up a lot of these um monuments
but
two things um b20.metapus.fund has all
the people collection so that's a
monument in the whatever so you have the
coordinates that's one
the other one is openc uh you can go to
openc and search metapos
and you will see our wallet full of uh
these digital art collection
fantastic that'll end our program for
the day medicoven you've been
absolutely fantastic for uh giving us so
much of your time